salut brut je m'appelle victor laura
j'ai 33 ans et je suis à la retraite
génération de nos parents et fallait
travailler juste pour pour soi et pour
financer sa retraite à la fin mais
aujourd'hui une vraie quête de liberté
finalement de pouvoir être soi même
s'occuper de soi même de sa vie et de
choisir quelle sera sa trajectoire
[Musique]
j'ai eu un déclic en fait un long
travail je pense comme pas mal de monde
achetés dans les lignes une du métro là
j'ai vu une femme assise d'une
quarantaine d'années entre 40 et 50 ans
et elle avait l'air un peu dépressive je
me suis dit voilà en gros moi je me
dirige directement vers ça donc fera
peut-être que je réfléchisse à quelque
chose et le soir j'ai regardé sur des
blogs américains comment on peut ne pas
travailler et là je me suis dit ok en
fait il ya un truc et ça a l'air de
marcher c'est très mathématique donc
premiers éléments moi j'ai commencé à
contrôler mon niveau de vie et après
quand j'ai commencé à bien investir
surtout en bourse et à comprendre le
pouvoir de l'epargne là je suis devenu
totalement drastique donc j'économisais
70 à 80 % de ce que ce que je gagnais et
on a enfin ça c'est vraiment beaucoup
d'efforts donc ça veut dire même si vous
êtes habitués aller au restaurant vous y
avait quasiment plus volées - vos amis
vous mettez en colocation vous partez
quasiment peu en vacances clash venue
assez drastiques là dessus cette hygiène
de vie la halle et aussi avec le fait
que je commençais à beaucoup à côté de
mon job travailler pour faire des
investissements donc que ce soit à
l'immobilier ça prend beaucoup de temps
donc je passais mes week-ends à essayer
de trouver des immeubles des
appartements achetés et du coup le week
end principalement le samedi je partais
très tôt donc je prends toujours les
premiers trains des plus tôt pour aller
dans d'autres villes et il ya un moment
j'ai investi c'est pas mal à 3 la vie de
troy qui à 1h30 de paris quand j'ai
commencé je gagnais dans les trois 3 à
4000 euros par mois donc j'avais à
l'époque 21 ans 22 ans et j'ai mis du
coup pour atteindre un premier stade
j'ai mis neuf ans après une dizaine
d'années à mes 30 ans finalement mes
dépenses étaient couvertes par mes
investissements donc investissements en
bourse investissements en immobilier et
des business que j'avais à côté ça
voudrait vraiment quand même à des gens
qui sont et au fil en général avec +5
très diplômés est ce que c'est possible
de faire ce mouvement avec des salaires
des salaires moindres le salaire médian
en france c'est quand même de 1400 euros
donc il faut dire que il ya la moitié
des français la moitié des français qui
sont en dessous de ça on a une chance
particulière en france c'est que
l'immobilier et l'emprunt immobilier est
accessible au plus grand nombre
c'est dû à la france dû au système
bancaire qu'on a en france et du coup on
peut plus faire un fire pour les petits
revenus on peut faire un fire grâce à
l'immobilier par contre aujourd'hui les
règles se durcissent donc il faut voir
et aussi quand on a des faibles revenus
dès qu'on a le moindre pépin dans son
plan fire ça risque d'être un peu
compliqué donc c'est prendre plus que
plus de risque finalement ce qui a
changé dans mon quotidien depuis que
juif ailleurs c'est que là aujourd'hui
vu que je décide de tout ce que je fais
dans ma vie et je décide de mon temps
finalement je choisis de me lancer dans
un projet je choisi d'avoir adressé tel
problème et ça franchement c'est
fantastique c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
tous les matins quand je me lève je suis
vraiment vraiment heureux de ma vie je
souris je suis content même s'il ya des
choses bons qui sont à régler avant par
exemple les générations de nos parents
c'était il fallait faire des études
comprendre un secteur avec des
informations qui étaient très dures à
trouver avoir un job et potentiellement
faire le même job toute sa vie et
travailler juste pour bat pour soi et
pour financer sa retraite à la fin mais
aujourd'hui nous on est dans un monde
qui est beaucoup plus ouverte cirque ya
une vraie quête de liberté finalement de
pouvoir être soi même s'occuper de soi
même de sa vie et de choisir quelle sera
sa trajectoire je pense que le niveau de
dépressions et burnout a quand même
augmenté en tout cas ce qu'il en ressort
c'est qu'on dit ok si à un moment je
suis pas bien et que j'ai envie de faire
un break et peut-être prendre un mois
pour aller je suis pas au fin fond de la
bourgogne franche comté pour être dans
une maison et faire un break ben faut
que je puisse le faire et du coup faut
que je me sépare de ce besoin d'argent
et là je pense que c'est assez fort sur
nos générations